for 13 years Mohammed Murad has biked to
work at the nearby power station and he
has continued to do so despite not
having been paid since the beginning of
this year he is among hundreds of
government contractors in Baghdad whose
salaries have been delayed because of a
deepening fiscal crisis brought about by
the sharp decline in oil prices I don't
care about the oil prices if it's going
up or going down because I don't get a
benefit from it I just demand my salary
it's the most basic right as an Iraqi
citizen with 3 million employees the
government is Iraq's biggest employer
thousands more like Mohammad are
subcontracted as part of government
projects they are the first to feel the
pinch as authorities are forced to
tighten spending if these projects can't
get funded they will stop as a result
the salaries will also stop for the
daily workers in addition to this maybe
the economic crisis will also impact the
salaries of the permanent staff the
Iraqi government relies on oil for
nearly 90 percent of its revenues the
2020 draft budget was calculated at $56
per barrel with six point six billion
dollars in oil income expected every
month but in March Iraq earned only two
point nine nine billion dollars at a
price of $28 per barrel that has left it
over a billion dollars short of the four
point seven billion dollars it needs for
salaries and Pensions alone cutting
salaries is an unpopular measure so what
other options does the government have
borrowing is one but is mostly a cash
based economy so banks have a small
deposit base they discount in the
central bank so the more reserves we use
the less we have to support our current
foreign funding certainly possible
because the issue with that is any
foreign borrowing will not come without
let's say a serious economic reforms the
government has resisted such reforms in
the past now matters have been further
complicated by a political crisis month
of protests have left the government
leaderless and unable to approve this
year's budget let alone mount a decisive
response to the economic crisis the next
government will have no choice but to
introduce
austerity measures and that is likely to
spark a new cycle of unrest Muhammad
doesn't have time to wait for a new
government to put food on the table he's
been borrowing money from friends and
family and taking credits at his local
shop if we stay like this without
salaries we cannot provide food for our
families we will see a decline in our
living standards
analysts say what Iraq needs are
structural reforms to diversify its
economy create private-sector jobs
downsize its public sector and stop
corruption but such reforms need time
time Iraq currently does not have simona
14 al jazeera baghdad